hello everyone and welcome today to
delays live broadcast and panel
discussion on complementary vs.
companion diagnostics we have panelists
today Martin Shaw who's the business
development manager at arrow cell and
Professor Thomas Webster the department
chair of chemical engineering at
Northeastern University
I'm dr. Annette Gilchrist from
Midwestern university and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar being presented by lab
routes the scientific social networking
website before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the panel discussion to do
so you're going to click on the ask a
question box that's located on the far
left of your screen you're going to type
your question into the drop down box
that appears will answer as many
questions since we have time for at the
end of the presentation if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the help desk
button this located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen alternatively you can just ask a
question in the ask a question box and
let someone know that you're having a
problem any questions that we don't have
time for today will be followed up with
via email our discussion is educational
and this offers continuing education
credits you can click on the continuing
education credit tab that's located in
the top right corner of the presentation
window and you're going to follow the
process to obtain your C credits for now
though please join me in welcoming our
panelists perhaps you would each like to
introduce yourself and tell us what your
interest is in Diagnostics complimentary
versus companion dr. Webster maybe you
would start sure and thank you for for
this invitation and opportunity
to share my thoughts so I'm currently as
was mentioned the department chair of
chemical engineering here at
Northeastern University in Boston
I have spent maybe about 20 years
looking at nanotechnology and how
nanoparticles and other nanotechnology
approaches can be used to both diagnose
and treat different diseases and one of
those of course has been cancer so I'm
very interested in this discussion of
companion versus complementary
diagnostic tools since I I do see a very
interesting future in the Diagnostics
area for four different cancers as well
as infection and other diseases mr. Shaw
okay and my name is Martin Shore on
Business Development Manager of iris lav
we develop novel biomarkers for cancer
studies I've been involved in the
development of biomarkers for about 40
years right from the very early days
when OSC and I follow the long so I've
got a lot of experience it's mostly what
you would call the field of
complementary biomarkers rather than
companion dying markers but both have
got their place and this exciting time
to be in a laboratory development field
thank you very inviting me to take part
well thank you both so I'm actually
going to start with you I'm mr. Shaw and
ask you perhaps if you would mind
defining complementary diagnostics and
how they differ from companion
diagnostics for those of us who don't
know I think there's a difference in
registration in the companion diagnostic
is registered together with the drug for
which is appropriate and is linked to
rather closely to particularly drug it
is generally expected to be compulsory
to assay a companion diagnostic before
you use the equipment drug addition
always done complementary biomarkers are
tests that are considered to be useful
in the choice of drug but not essential
first choice
I think that complimentary diagnostics
is a bit of a loose term because a way
taking a patient's temperature is a
complimentary diagnostic so it's just
about every lab tests but then it's
become to be applied more to the more
recent proteomics going on we derived
tests run into traditional laboratory
chemistry so I think that's basically
difference between them great thank you
um so I I think that that's important
right the difference between them the
regulations that I'm sure required for
one versus the other that's gonna
ultimately I think open the field up for
the complimentary Diagnostics right
isn't that an idea that they'll really
be able to have more of them because
there's less requirements that underlie
their use and when they can be used and
when they can't be used yeah I mean I
think it said you'll find I think that
one of the things about complementary
Diagnostics is that they they likely to
come from unexpected places and that you
might find that a drug sorry a
laboratory test which was not designed
to study a certain disease is found to
have a value there and complementary
Diagnostics been around for many many
years like cytochrome p450s have been
around for don't know how many years and
they really are the original
complementary Diagnostics but they're
not considered so in the sort of field
that we're talking about now things like
testing for warfare in juice you really
should do a complementary iweb make
diagnostic which is the p450 status but
it's not done I know probably today
floss warfarin was launched p450 would
be a companion diagnostic right right
certainly thank you so much
um so dr. Webster do you think you could
provide some more examples of
complementary diagnostic versus
companion diagnostics sure yeah and I
definitely appreciate the thought
process that perhaps we have more
complementary diagnostic tools than
maybe what we're acknowledging so I
think a great example of companion
diagnostics is really the hurt
to breast cancer diagnostic tool that I
believed was you know approved in the
late 1990s and there of course the idea
is is very traditional right you you
identify a marker on a cancer cell that
might be exclusive to a sub population
of patients and in this case it was the
human epidermal growth factor receptor
tube that was exclusive to a sub
population of breast cancer patients and
based on a positive diagnostic test you
then have approval for a therapeutic
agent that's specific to that that
molecular indicator so that I think
that's how a lot of us think about
diseases and diagnostic tools you test
for a specific receptor if it's there
then a drug follows or approval of youth
where we're sort of the controversy I
suppose comes into play is comparing
that with these complementary diagnostic
tools where you you don't necessarily
need to do a complementary diagnostic
tool in order to prescribe drugs for a
disease so it's recommended just like
the term as it's complementary so it's
recommended but it's not required and I
think the than another example of a
complementary diagnostic tool that a lot
of people discuss is really PDL one
right which is the program death ligands
one which is used for different cancers
from melanoma to small lung nonce no
lung carcinomas where again you could
have a diagnostic tool or not and end up
prescribing a certain drug in the
complementary case so we actually talked
about the mysteries this morning this
PDL one monoclonal antibodies and I
think another great example of the
companion diagnostics really has to be
the Alka el fusion
again for non-small-cell lung cancer
were only a small percentage of patients
actually have that mutation and the drug
itself which is targeted against ALK is
certainly not going to be useful and
unless the patients actually have that
mutation so that makes right sense right
if you have a known genetic difference
where the drug is going to be useful or
not useful in the case of the b-raf
right inhibitors right you really have
to have the mutation or that patients
actually don't do as well that it makes
perfect sense then that those would have
a companion diagnostic that is required
but I do think that we have a lot of
information to be gained by companion
diagnostics makes perfect sense right
where more information is useful and
trying to decide between perhaps which
therapy to use absolutely you know in
fact of a great topic to think about
when comparing a companion to
complementary is I think there are many
people who believe that going down the
road of companion diagnostics really
gets you to more personalized medicine
you know and this is a great thing to
think about this does it really get you
to more personalized medicine or not but
the idea among many in the in the field
is in order to make headway in cancer
and some of these other diseases you
really have to personalize the
diagnostic tool as well as the treatment
to those specific mutations that you're
talking about if you can personalized
medicine then I think there's a hope
that it would be more effective so by
linking a diagnostic tool with a
treatment a therapeutic treatment you
can make an argument I think that it is
more personalized than not requiring the
diagnostic tool to be used as in the
case of a complementary treatment yeah I
would say the other problem is once they
become a companion diagnostic and
they're required right you
the risk for example insurance companies
not covering if you don't have for
example the mutation but they know with
like the estrogen receptors that
sometimes patients will respond who have
estrogen receptor negative cancers to in
fact estrogen inhibitors and so you know
you run that risk right then you make it
required but it might still be a useful
drug for that patient and I see in the
UK is demanding that some drugs are only
given if there's a positive companions
for a complementary test because of the
enormous costs or somebody's modern
living a service right so we're going to
get back to you mr. Schad you do you
think that the distinction then between
the complementary diagnostic and the
companion diagnostic is important do you
think that is good that we have both
types I don't think it's important very
much I think it sometimes it's a
commercial decision if you are
developing this new super expensive
immunotherapy you've got a companion
diagnostic which you also control then
you have a commercial advantage whereas
if you're just taking okay we run a
serum creatinine because we want to see
the kidney function there's really not
much more money in it for that so I
think there is a there is a commode
there is a difference but I suppose
there's no reason why I pharmacy or
Chrome is should not develop a
complementary diagnostic particularly
there's a lot of crossover between the
ownership of like are not promoting or
criticizing for some Abbott and Rho
sugar could huge pharmaceutical and use
Diagnostics divisions so they they're in
good position to do this but I think the
thing is that complementary Diagnostics
are easier to launch and I think
something this as a lab person I'm a bit
dubious about is the this has been very
little demo call a vacation of the
laboratory fullness of these
complementary and companion tests if
you've got an immune in immunological
drug and you'll do an enamine OSA for it
you can get apparently identical results
when you
run control samples but then we get out
into the clinic you find there are some
people react very differently this is
through about every immunoassay so I do
I would wonder sometimes why don't the
pharmaceutical companies say you can
only use antibody ABC or so on I don't
think they're allowed to but it would be
restraint of trade but if you're looking
at a biological that could be porn and
when you get a me to buy a similar and
you're still using the same PD one
antibody screening is it the same
I've been done many many essays I know
that this is not always the same it
might be only one in 100 or it might be
20 in a hundred but you use it
anybody ability to assay seen this hmm
yes so I think people great points right
and you could really drive yourself
perhaps a little crazy when you start
thinking from a company viewpoint and
we've started a couple of companies in
this area so I've been in these
conversations of which one is more
economically beneficial for you
you know complementary versus cap an yin
and certainly at the points that were
just raised really highlight that
controversy right if it's if it's a
linked to your if your diagnostic tool
is linked to your therapeutic well
that's great commercially right may not
be the the best for health care but it's
certainly great commercially but
similarly on the other hand for
complementary you know if you can have
if you have a therapy that doesn't rely
on your diagnostic kids then how
commercials successful and that be so I
I think there's there's really a very
interesting push and pull from the
economics I think one area though that
we all should be conscious of is the
field of theranostics writing in the
field of bus you indices in the field of
theranostics really it's one material
many times the nanoparticle that's
combining the diagnostic therapy so in
the field of theranostics that the two
are linked
you know and you have the same material
doing both so if that field continues
and people continue to to show that you
functionalize a nanoparticle specific
flag and for you know a cancer cell
receptor and then medicine treats that
cancer cell kills the cancer cell are we
are these fools mute you know sure what
is the role really for a separate
diagnostic tool and and and that's you
know a temporal thing to think about
yeah I think that's a great point it's
not even one that we have to discuss in
the panel but I think it makes absolute
sense to talk about right because
they're completely um driving some of
the new technology with these
theranostics right I mean there's
there's quite an interest where you can
diagnose and treat at the same time and
it and it's not just you know the
individual particle that people are
looking at but there is a growing sensor
implantable sensor community that is
again at the same time you diagnose you
have a therapy there's a lot of this of
course in type 2 diabetes implantable
sensor activity but but it really you
know does highlight if it's linked
shion's going to be important in the
future between companion and
complimentary yep my apologies I've no
idea what's in the air in Chicago
something is clear here so um do you
think dr. Webster that you can follow up
with that and maybe talk about the
difference between complementary and
companion diagnostics and how that
correlates with actually some of the FDA
requirements for what is required versus
a recommended test yeah I was gonna win
on one in terms of how those are how
those worked right and this is actually
very interesting and excellent that you
know
there's a the FDA versus what's going on
in Europe in in terms of these
diagnostic tools right so you know as as
we discussed in the in the companion a
diagnostic tool that is approved by the
FDA and then the follow of therapy of
course is approved by the FDA as well so
in in Europe it's different right as I
understand it in Europe the the
diagnostic tool that's used in companion
therapies or any therapies are just C II
marked right so they're they're deemed
safe to use but they don't carry FDA
approval stamp as what occurs in the US
and and you know again as with
everything there's there's sort of pros
and cons to that it definitely I think
makes less of a link between that tool
and the diagnostic tool in the eventual
therapy you know in the FDA system they
are linked and you have a competition or
word in obviously want to develop a
diagnostic tool and a therapy to the FDA
approved but if the diagnostic tool is C
marked is that linked as much to the
therapy it's an important consideration
but at the moment it isn't but the as a
discussion paper is sent out by the
European medical authorities which will
come closer to the American standard it
won't be exactly the same the new we but
it's very similar that why say they're
going to be currently they're rated as
low risk products just like a thyroxine
SS thing like that but they will be up
regular up the registration requirements
will be changed so they'll become a high
risk diagnostic such as I do an HIV test
so that will become pretty closer to the
American system not the same appointment
with exact wording is but it's not the
same wording but it's very similar in
application so along those same lines
mr. Shah do you think that the type of
test and whether it's actually
standardized should make a difference
between whether something is compliment
a companion are they typically antibody
assays or they typically IHC assays you
know does that make a difference well I
think companion assays are really all
coming out to be genetic or antibody
base because you're trying to get so
specific inist you a lot to do with
personalized medicine but is may be
losing a point but there's no reason
what they should be
it could be an enzyme activity IC or
something like that I wonder how much
lost your question there a bit and I'm
sorry if I may have done that that's
okay do you have anything dad on that no
professor
that's just yes I would
I would just add and I'm sure Martin
would would agree with me that I think
standardization is is pretty important
and in all of this so I think
standardization for any of these assays
these diagnostic tools that can then
link to a therapy is pretty important
you know it's pretty important to
compare apples and apples for the
research it's pretty important to be
treating patients with a high degree of
standardization yum this is a there's
two ways to go the most standard day it
is the few patience you have that's true
the other thing is the more standard it
is the more control the person who has
developed companion pair of drug and
test has they could even get to a state
of been a monopoly situation restraint
of trade
if you said as I think it's a great idea
it's got to be antibody ABC with drug X
Y Zed company making drug X Y they would
love that but I think maybe the
monopolies Commission would not like it
I can certainly see your and commercial
bench Martin you're clearly coming at
this from the business side and versus
the research side because I think right
for many aspects of the standardization
has to do with be reimbursed and and at
at what level is that reimbursement and
what's the cost of the essay itself and
how does that make a difference and
could it be done by
a lot of different people or does it
need to be done in a single laboratory
so and I think you know those things are
very important questions and I think
maybe we don't quite know the answers to
some of those questions yet but just to
add an additional intriguing thought to
this discussion is we have been talking
about cancer and certainly in the field
of companion and complementary
diagnostic tools cancer has been a main
driver but if you think about what's
been happening in infectious diseases
commercially we have a real issue you
know where many companies aren't seeing
a commercial value in developing new
antibiotics or new strategies to reduce
antibiotic resistant bacteria but when
you have a partial bottom fall out of
some of those companies in some of those
efforts then what's left you know and
and of course the reason for some of
this in the infectious diseases area is
because the FDA has not been approving
new antibiotics because you have to show
that they won't developed antibiotic
resistant but think about you know the
potential future of having companion or
complementary discussion diagnostic tool
discussions for infectious diseases and
wouldn't it be great to have some of
these diagnostic tools that could then
lead to a prescribed molecule to kill a
bacteria that doesn't involve an
antibiotic so just to add a different
dimension it's not always about cancer
in some of these discussions there are
many diseases that are important to
discuss and linking of the diagnostic
tool to therapy and I think it means
excess diseases there are really
complementary Diagnostics like
susceptibility testing but they need to
be faster and easier and in some ways
you said getting to these new
antibiotics quicker and they're going to
be expend more expensive so they could
justify the extra cost
and so I actually think that that flows
nicely into the next question which has
to do with how will next generation
sequencing and the decreased cost of
like whole genome sequencing how is that
going to play into whether you have a
complementary tests done because if
you've had your whole genome sequence
you know you may not need that
information for a complimentary test you
may already have it sitting on a you
know USB Drive somewhere and and so the
question is do you think that that's
going to matter right if I have my whole
genome sequence do I need a
complimentary test
maybe I already know whether my sip 3a4
is working properly or not
that me or Thomas you would like fine um
I'm actually going to ask you that okay
well I think the thing is one of the
points about cancers now that they're
going into cheap old genome sequences
there almost every even within a
apparently opportunities to mothers if
there is a variation of genetic profile
there's also variations in gene
expression depending on the blood
vasculature and the oxygen tension and
exposure to the drugs so I think it's
going to be that you're going to be with
Luke's will be biopsies you're going to
be screening the liquid but the DNA in
blood and that will continuously go to
new companion complementary Diagnostics
for a patient through the course of
their disease so it's going to it's
going to I think you're probably going
to end up with a complimentary stroke
event unless it's one in early breast
cancer number two later on number three
four five six seven as the disease
mutates and progresses in the drugs new
drugs are developed but maybe you make a
chip with several seven on to begin with
them so is that way but is then this
enormous YouTube mutation rate of
cancers is going to need to develop more
and more companion diagnostics very
personalized ones yeah so I would
definitely agree with that you know I
think genome sequencing wouldn't that be
great to have the scenario that you
described where everybody's you know
genome has been sequenced and you can
prescribe a therapeutic based on that
but you know as was I think correctly
stated there is a dynamic part to
treating cancer right and there are
cancer stem cell research that's going
on right there's there's a chemo
therapeutic resistant cancer cells that
develop based upon your prescribed
treatment all of these things are very
dynamic so it I think it's a one
solution
you know fits all is certainly not going
to happen but even after having genome
sequencing I think you still have to
have variability you still have to
understand that dynamic process to have
a really efficient treatment strategy so
I think it is you just answered one of
the other questions which had to do
about the genetic character Janani of
tumors because that's been a clear issue
then I don't know that we really
appreciated ten years ago right but as
we've sequenced more of the cells when
you can sequence individual cells you
recognize that there are differences
genetically from one cancer cell to the
next cancer cell is sitting right next
to it right and so some of the cells may
express some genes and some may not
right and so how you treat that cancer
you know you're going for the whole
population that you're treating not just
one specific cell yeah so I think this
room yeah jumped at the technical point
and and we need you know of course a lot
more research on the heterogeneity of
tumors you know what is the
communication between these
heterogeneous cells I mean there's so
many issues that are involved in that
and that's why I really you know I've
although you have success stories of
using one single drug on a tumor
how do you use one drug that can fight
the heterogeneity of a tumor you know it
is a critical question and and that's
where we really could start thinking
about adaptable materials you know again
the theranostics idea that we previously
talked about and
ouch that that change it is with the
changing tumor treatment is critical I
think in the future of somebody's really
hard to kill cancer cancer areas and
certainly the ones that have become
resistant right because of treatment
that's already been given absolutely so
I'm actually going to end with a
question that I'm not sure that you can
answer but it's one that I was curious
about and that is um how do you think
that the insurance industry actually
views the complementary versus the
companion diagnostic in terms of the
reimbursement do they reimburse for both
do they recognize that both are
necessary and so they're willing to pay
for those or you know is it more one
versus the other I think from Europe
it's a bit in flux but I think the trend
is very strongly towards you don't get
the drug if you don't do the test you um
you just it's one thing if you're giving
even like a penicillin this your
business capability test but if you're
looking at a immunotherapy that can cost
hundreds of thousands of dollars it's
not going to be reimbursed unless you
spend tested somebody's test costs
$7,000 or something like that they're
quite highly priced and I suppose the
point about it is from the
pharmaceutical industry is that it's the
drug is 100,000 and the test is 7,000
and I've got to pay the lab for that and
this losses down the line so I think
that's from that point of view but there
is going to be in Europe push for the
fact you don't unless you do the tests
you don't get the drug and it's also new
I know for example in France when they
were setting HIV testing for HIV
therapeutics that if the drug fails they
don't pay the pharmaceutical company and
I think that's also some drugs in the UK
but I can't remember the names so
there's a mutual advantage to go into
companion diagnostics rather than maybe
you've got more experience of the u.s.
system yeah so I can add only a little
bit so that you know I think certainly
in the companion system
there's a history of reimbursement
strategies right so you know you have a
firm diagnostic tool that's been
approved by the FDA it's standardized
and the follow up treatment
that is a reimbursable strategy in the
complementary case I do know you know
reimbursable of quarter strategies using
complementary systems where it's really
up to the clinician to make some of
those decisions and that's valued pretty
highly you know in a reimbursement
strategy so there are some cases
certainly the points notwithstanding
without having a diagnostic tool
you know the reimbursement strategy
could be a little bit more difficult but
if you rely on the expertise of the
clinician to treat that particular
cancer that can be I think what can be
sensitive is the fact that as you
mentioned earlier on about issue gene
receptors and anti anagen anterior
issues in therapy there are a minority
of people who are totally negative for a
biomarker but still react still respond
possible to the drug yes I think it's
going to vary in some ways if the
patient demands it and the doctor knows
that these drugs tend to be rather not
toxic or compared to the traditional
chemotherapy is he going to say no are
they going to have to fight with the
insurance company about it and because
there is a you know you've got everybody
knows false positives and false
biological positives and false
biological negatives in yes biology
absolutely and that's what brings in
your comment is very interesting and
it'll be fascinating to watch how that
unfolds in Europe that if you developed
a therapeutic agent that does not show
success is that reimbursable you know
that that is fascinating to me and you
know well certainly a lot to show in the
field if that you know if that bears out
well I think the thing in Europe is is
I'll say I know to UK better than most
places is if it doesn't work you don't
come to us and get paid that's what
they're trying to do to get the in the
price negotiations with the
pharmaceutical companies they are saying
over I use we're going to give you
so many dollars tens of thousands of
dollars for if it works but if it
doesn't work you take the hit so it's
very much in the pharmaceutical
company's interest to sue okay there has
to be some faders otherwise you're
missing people but they want to keep the
balance in Kannamma CLE between treating
patients who don't respond and getting
all the patients who do respond so that
means there will be patients who are
more likely necessarily because their
pictures such that the doctor thinks
it's worth a try yes it's a fascinating
idea and and you know has huge
ramifications for for these drug
companies writing and and how do you
develop strategies to bring a drug to
market I mean there's a lot of really
fascinating things to keep an eye on if
that know it well this is something
that's been discussed in the industry is
the fact is that you do your pricing
strategy based on the fact that a
certain percentage of your patients will
respond and you price the drug
accordingly so that you know like in the
UK they have a quality of life years I
think it's saying like sixty thousand
pounds as that would under eighty
thousand dollars a year
I may be wrong there don't quote me so
they may put the processor and live with
it including the ones who do not respond
and not send a drug doesn't work this is
biology and the quality of life here on
average for the responders and
non-responders
works out at eighty thousand dollars and
if you can make it worth ninety thousand
dollars then you get a positive from the
authorities it works out adding all the
pluses and minuses seventy thousand
sorry because I got it exactly right
wrong around if any cost seventy
thousand dollars for the Q at quality of
life here you're great and it cost
ninety thousand they make ask you to
trivia prices yeah I think that's the
best any idea right when I think of like
the the voluma map for ctla4 that's
given for melanoma but only 20% of the
patients actually respond to it but
those that do right they have a much
better survival and so you you know what
happens for the eighty
percent the job right I mean that's just
amazing to me that idea that they
wouldn't get reimbursed at the pharma
companies with you I really imagine how
much more expensive that those drugs
would become so we'll keep an eye on
that right well you know what's your
push DN I see this on their website and
they sort of thing about their
discussions they have and it tends to
get into popular press as well
I'm fascinated so I certainly want to
thank both of our panelists for their
participation today I'd also like to
thank laberd's for making today's
educational discussion possible before
we go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through the end of May
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event and
that's all for now we thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon
good bye thank you bye